I'm Bobbie I'm Laura I'm Nathan my name
is Roger I don't know how to cook I do
not cook like the other day we made a
salad that was just opening bags and
dumping them in a bowl and you still
manage to do that
wrong we have set off so many fire
alarms that we have done that thing we
just like take the fire alarm out I know
that I'm going to be making brunch for
Bobby today brunch is the meal that has
the best drinks
I feel like breakfast food is the best
food without question are you ready to
find out what I'm making I'm ready
[Music]
eggs benedict
one of my top prospects i've never
poached an egg maybe this might be hard
welcome to at home with Roger it's me
Roger I'm gonna start with off to a
great start
okay so make the hollandaise poach the
eggs cook the bacon is not half a stick
for one egg yolk okay great no nope
nothing better welcome back to at home
with Roger I think it looks like
hollandaise this part I feel okay about
can do take it little nervous about the
bacon it's looking a little sweaty but
maybe the eggs will poach themselves
next we'll call that good all right
they're in there so whatever is gonna
happen to them it's gonna happen to them
it looks like it's full of ghosts
honestly that looks great I'm pretty
impressed right now assuming the
hollandaise sauce over we can dump it
out stunning and I made this horrifying
smiley face for a time right Bobby I'm
very excited oh yeah look at this are
you ready to see what I prepared for you
cuz it readies I'm gonna guess that's
not a pepper I just got a big hit a dill
pepper I do like that you really and in
to the garnish element on this I got a
little overexcited and almost a dumped
everything
I think it's time to eat it over you do
this together yeah let's do this
together
whoo Ronnie all right look at her nice
running so smoothly I'm impressed
how is it it's a lot of pepper this
might be the best thing you've ever made
guess how many times I had to restart
[Music]
how are you gonna afford you question
tell us something to drink
well Navin I'm very proud of you I think
you did a really great job thanks honey
Cheers
to not having to do the heavy lifting in
the kitchen
[Music]